well give to this hmm sorry welcome to
this video the first video for them
waited eagerly anticipated match between
world champion Vishwanath and Magnus
cars and the Challenger I need some of
the extensive pre-match videos 20 videos
showing the best games or some great
games of the players not necessarily the
best ones hard to choose but now we get
to the real match the first game has
been played today and yeah let's get
right to the game itself
cars are playing white and is playing
Knight f3 it's always hard to guess what
opening he will play he plays all moves
or main moves and yeah Knight f3 is one
of them but still not the most frequent
choice before was probably thousands
mammals but here Knight f3 was played
which can mean different things
just some move order tricks or some
independent opening we see that Anand is
replying with d5 so here's some more
prepared in for Queen's Gambit
structures white um quite often now just
plays d4 and after 90 f6 Knight f6 z 4
we get a Queen's Gambit the Queens
gambit declined I was laughs yeah kept
erratically could also play the accepted
a lot has done this in the past in the
past not the past for the past
alright so deformed normally live but
cards plays g3 steering the game until
you have more unconventional channels
this is some leading to generate a
opening or the Kings Indian attack type
of
we're wide fianchettoed fianchetto sand
then plays like that in the center Kings
Indian attack or place with c4 in the
style of the the reti opening the pure
ready opening a sea form but this is
somewhat out of fashion because of the
reply default white really wants to play
this kind of reverse Ben Oni
so players who like something like that
for example for white or that for what
just delaying default very often start
with the two g3 and only later play see
for incidentally this is also my main
opening as white so I'm able to to tell
some things about that okay I'll now
place the move g6 and it's really funny
coincidence this is my system is black
against this opening I play one d5 and
on g3 I play g6 and it's a very very
good solid way to to open this black the
main way to play instead of g6 is
normally to go something like c6 Bishop
out to g4 then Knight f6 and e6 this is
somewhat similar to a London system with
d4 Bishop f4 and so on but with the
colors reversed this is an alternative
setup g3 has a specific idea I'm going
to show that on Bishop g2 Carlton played
and Bishop g7 and by the way Arnold has
never played to g6 so this is a new idea
for his opening repertoire yeah what
black is doing this quick fianchetto
actually aims to control the e5 square
so black is intending to occupy the
center with e5 if white now just castles
black is able to play e5 and yeah you
don't don't get
the opportunity to offer this black to
build up a full center after four moves
so this is always some something to to
welcome if you're able to do that white
rally allows this kind of setup and
reacts after Bishop g7 and the reaction
is usually default or C form one of
those moves if I'm white and this
position it can happen I can I can have
this position with both colors I would I
would personally play C for him and
attack the center with the C pawn after
that black has a choice he can support
the pawn with c6 with e6 or Knight f6
just cover it you don't want to take
with the Queen after the capture or
black can push the pawn to d4 so it was
and now we have the same situation as
mentioned before after the pure ready
but now black is committed to a bishop
on g7 which is a possible line but not
the line probably black would have
chosen none if he still have the
opportunity to to set up differently so
this is an alternative for white cause a
choice however is another one
he played deform of course also a good
move stopping e5 very directly and the
Ireland is going for an interesting
choice and a good choice something that
maybe should look at I never really
studied the move he played now the move
c6 which is a little detail but a good
one an interesting one the
normal-looking move of course is Knight
f6 just going for complete symmetry the
point of the move c6 is that after
Knight f6 here white will probably place
you form and now if black captures on
c-4 black and generally has two ways to
play this position
allow the Captur he can support with c6
I can take himself here he actually
after taking him staking himself
white could go night a3 and just get the
pawn back there should be six is not
particularly great in the game to spot
the difference he played c6 if white now
would play a quick c4 let's say just
here then black cut really thinking of
just taking it and the problem is that
now 93 can be answered simply by b5 so
yeah it's just a pawn
so c6 is a move to discourage the c4
push which would be rather normal for
white to play c4 here but it's not so
easy now because black with the early c6
somehow prepares the capture we see that
after castles this is what Carson played
on a place Knight f6 and again if c4
black can take and he has not cathode
yet and spent this on c6 so he has
really ideas to to keep the pawn if
white for example here would play 95
protecting the pawn trying to get it
back besides the simple Bishop e6 to
cover it black even has this nice idea
very direct play and the ideas after
Knight c4 you're just hanging default so
what must be careful with c4 he probably
should prepare the movement Carson is
doing just that he plays b3 preparing c4
yeah and canceling very normal
and now there should be two this is all
very standard Bishop f5 good developing
move of course and now see form you
cannot really play without the rules you
need to put some pressure on the center
otherwise it is just too tame
night bd7 and yeah right now here on the
nine we already had a very important
point of this game we see that black is
completely developed scott caan are
completely
he's got all minor pieces in play and
has castled he has not really found
places for the rooks but in this quite
close position this is not easy at all
in this concrete position here white of
course has to decide what to do with his
minor piece on b1 this Knight needs to
be in a plate but but well and it seems
that Carla's move now which looks
completely natural it's a mistake
he plays Knight c3 it's a common move I
found there more than 30 games in my
database with that but 30 games nowadays
is not much we already at a relatively
rare position after this game I think
it's this move Knight c3 will be yea
relegated to the dustbin probably
because it's not playing for nem for
anything we see what happens in the game
Knight bTW to is probably the way to go
the main ideas that this Knight adds
further stability for the c4 pawn and
this is probably what weiter should do
try to keep the game interesting I think
the position is probably you know
somewhere between equal and very very
slightly better for white simply based
on the fact that white is the one to
have a bit of pressure in the center but
it's it's not very spectacular at all
the setup with d5 and d6 is fianchetto
group thought were c6 this is what we
transpose into is generally considered
to be a very solid for black
and I personally doubt that we will see
this position again in the magic so it's
very very little that white can play for
of course Carson's the kind of player
that does not need any big advantages
out of the opening but still this is a
very very very little in the game he
played 93 and as mentioned I think this
this turns out to be a not so great for
your wife I now place some simple and
strong he took on c4 and of course a
move that needs to be justified with
technical means otherwise it doesn't
make much sense to capture with your
deep on on c4 to trade a central pawn
against and not so great be pawn but it
has a concrete idea as usual Knight b6
is the idea attacking of the c4 pawn
this is a weakness now this is why 92
has the benefit of captive from
protecting c4 the night here is doing
nothing to protect your weak pawn and
white needs to react now what to do with
the pawn yeah you can you can cover or
you can advance let's look briefly at
covering the pawn let's say I'm Queen b3
this is the move that is probably the
most natural tribe to to cover yeah here
black can actually just play Bishop d6
to increase the pressure and here it's
difficult for white if you know try to
kept to to cover c4 you already have to
reckon with technical solutions 95 or
such a move that that covers c4 but
black yeah by the way black can also
take on d4 but this is probably a bit
risky a position like that could be
quite promising for white but it's not
necessary at all from blacks
who black he has a strong movement and
this is this pseudo sacrifice just
taking him and playing b5 you get the
night back now and it's a very nice
position after Bishop c6 Bishop c4 yeah
then Queen needs to move again and then
probably just rook c8 we see that black
has some edge on the Queen side he's got
two against one and he's got this
annoying play on the C farm so this is
not good at all and after Queen b3
Bishop d6
what are the alternatives you need to do
something about c4
yeah what can try to make a push like d5
work but it's not really really enough
let's look at that 95 this is a point
pressurizing is 6 and d5 but black has
this funny reply and takes takes the
problem is white cannot really take on
b7 and 95 is just just walking it's a
it's really really a problem this pawn
on c4 Queen b3 is it's really leading to
nothing and yeah what else is there I
couldn't try 95 immediately but what
about this move attacking e5 and after
the knight on e5 has exchanged a move
c4 is really gone here it's almost
unplayable already if white takes for
example Queen takes it's just a double
attack
d form C form you know it's it's just
just not great after Knight b6 yeah
Council plate c5 and yeah of course not
C for now and black somehow has very
quickly activated his piece
says the night from b6 to c4 and yeah it
just the text the birth the bishop on b2
and yeah white of course and has a
problem here you don't really want to
give him the bishop and consider the
bishop pal but yeah what should you play
McCarroll at the end decided to play
Bishop c1 and Bishop c1 is basically
yeah it's already admitting that
something ran wrong but what else is
there you could have tried Queen b3 just
to avoid this yun developing of the
bishop but it's it's not great at all i
mean black can just take me to we can
try Bishop e6 and trying to provoke
another Queen move but also simply
taking and a move line let's say Queen
85 the black has many possible ideas
black has two bishops and it's not clear
what what is really rights really
playing for so it's not really leading
to much to allow the capture on me too
yeah he played Bishop c1 and maybe the
ideas to evict the knight from z4 later
and try to prove that you have an that
your additional sent upon means
something but it's already beyond those
general considerations black plays
strongly no 95 just putting pressure on
the c3 Knight and yeah now it's um it's
problematic the next move basically am
is a draw of her cousin plays Queen b3
and Queen b3 is just allowing a draw and
cousins also thought a while before we
played that but the problem already is
it's it's very hard to not play Queen b3
if you take on a d5 for example I mean
you need to address your hanging knight
on c3 so you you cannot cover it with
any move so you need to equip me three
okay but you need to play a creepy three
and accept the game continuation the
possible draw all you need to take and
after taking like has a very comfortable
choice even at first I thought all right
I could just just take with the pawn and
black is in Inwood shape which is true
he has a nice night on c4 I can play
possibly Bishop to e4 and another idea
is always to play at the right moment b6
and attack the pony on c5 black has a
very comfortable position in fact
besides that even Queen defined as a
move which looks a bit weird to put the
Queen directly into the view of the
light squared bishop but it's not really
an issue if white girls and I defy for
example you just play Queen e6 and it
turns out that white centres is reliable
a team especially the d4 pawn is a
problem look the eight it can easily be
attacked and if not 95 if white plays
slowly let's say Queen b3 the black has
got bishop before this is the idea
setting up this battery and it's very
difficult to get rid of those pieces in
the middle so this is an additional
option besides she takes d5 this
basically means that Knight takes d5 is
not leading to anything so cousin played
Queen b3 and now on I just went Knight
a5 attacking the Queen yeah you don't
have much choice you need to keep c3
covered so we went to a3 alternatively
Queen b3 as possible but after
I see for Queen b3 only move Knight a5
we are just repeating get in the game in
fact Queen a3 was played Knight c4 will
be 395 Queen a three-night c4 and the
draw so what an anti-climatic
development in this first game after all
this tension building up towards the
match we have this very short game won
unexpectedly very short game Carson is
really not the kind of player who
concedes good draws but sometimes it
just happens that you stumble into a
configuration where you simply cannot
avoid the draw as awful as it might feel
to you I guess he didn't like to draw
this game of course he wouldn't wanted
to fight but it can even happen tin in
situations where you are the much much
stronger player and sometimes also
stumble into a situation where you
simply cannot avoid it the draw in fact
I believe after if you look at if you
moves back after this sequence was
initiated it is in fact very difficult
to to avoid this because any
alternatives after that involve risks
that you probably don't want to take
council is really the kind of player who
takes practical risks risks and says
okay I want to continue I'm trying to
keep the game going and I'm willing to
to go to gamble a little but there is no
leeway for for any gambling here you
need to keep c4 here and do so by
pushing as we saw protecting does not
help and after that it's difficult 95 is
really playing for for disadvantage so
Queen b3 ously the only move really and
now while machine I think was content
with the quick draw in game 1 so
especially with black of course
so Knight a5 is what
plate and we have this draw yeah was it
possible form for black to to play form
for win here play for for more Jeff well
Sephora saying and how do you protect it
can try b5 dramatic moves hmm yeah maybe
this is maybe this is playable if you
are ambitious let's say why why it takes
then yeah probably just me takes I could
sorry the night is hanging I'm sorry you
need to secure the night first and then
after this take yeah maybe maybe you can
try that but well it's a match of 12
games and black in the first game a draw
is perfectly alright so I think Island
was content with this slide Susheela
psychological edge let's say and
certainly cards wanted wanted to have a
longer game and then make a fight out of
it but it's sometimes just happens you
stumble into this kind of situation
where you cannot do much and it's not
the same if in his preparation they
didn't expect this setup or maybe he
could just confuse some some move order
this is always possible that you believe
you will follow your preparation and
that you have it slightly confused and
it's probably not leading to disaster
but maybe to the situation where you
cannot escape this drawing routine so
I'm not exactly a great game his first
match game but we still have 11 games to
to come and I guess we can look forward
to Game two
does playing white curious to see what
kind of opening line he's going to
choose before default something else all
right I'll be back tomorrow to cover
game 2 hope you enjoyed it anyway
despite being a very short game I'll be
back tomorrow with game 2 thanks for
watching